j'aimerais que tu fasses une vidéo entre
vraiment pourri par exemple tu pourrais
prendre les ondes de radio comme thème
de vidéos et si elle dépasse un million
de vues je fais trois fois ta promo labs
et messieurs bonjour et bienvenue dans
cette vidéo écoutez récemment j'ai eu
envie c'est un peu comme une inspiration
ultime de faire une vidéo qu'elle ait
parlé des ondes radio du freestyle
incomplète complètement on discute un
peu des andes radio qu'on apprenne j'ai
une poupée vodoo à l'éffigie de gameplay
qu'on pourra planter méritait pas ça me
paraît vraiment bon programme et après
on pourrait essayer de de pirater un peu
les ondes radio qui est impensable de
parler ouais un peu situation where du
j'aimerais si tu tu veux bien commencer
par parler du rapport qui entre le
mentalisme et les ondes radio voilà ça
c'est fait ce chapitre là éclore
maintenant déjà de base en fait une onde
radio enfin une onde
vous imaginez une oscillation comme un
pendule qui oscille sauf qu'il faut
imaginer en fait que la vibration de
cette oscillation elle quitte son point
de départ pour continuer à avancer
donc elle va osciller comme une flaque
20 mois et comme un cas sur deux
exactement comme un caillou dans une
mare la base de ce qui est bon de raser
personnes
finalement donc c'est bon alors on
pourrait rentrer dans des détails très
technique du style la vitesse la
longueur d'onde la fréquence ouais
d'ailleurs la vitesse est égale à la
longueur d'onde fois
la fréquence il n'en restait plus qu'un
donc on est bon mais cette vidéo
deviendrai vitré relou alors
heureusement on a trouvé des petits
trucs un peu plus un peu plus
croustillant n'est ce pas à vous lire
par exemple la fréquence en fait c'est
un petit peu comme un canal de diffusion
on va dire telle radio c'est sûr telles
fréquences des radios
il ya même des fréquences comme ça qui
sont réservées où il ya la louer à la
reagan loi est justement les gsm c'est
pas le même que les fréquents scénario
et ses acteurs mais à chaque fois on
parle bien de la fréquence de ça la
fréquence de 3 hertz à 30 hertz avec une
longueur d'onde de 100000 km et utiliser
pourquoi par exemple est-ce que tu as
une croyance iii rs 1 c'est tout petit
très très petit c'est le bf celle
extrêmement basses fréquences manquez
donc pas micro-ondes encore plus petits
mois devait coûte une bonne question
pour des trucs naturel oui exactement
pour les élections des phénomènes
naturels
c'est incroyable d'ailleurs il ya aussi
une détection des phénomènes naturels à
l'ultra basses fréquences qui est de 326
à noter que verse aussi en salle on
retrouve genre des super campagne alors
que la radiodiffusion elle c'est de 3
méga hertz à 30 mégahertz intéressant
n'est-ce pas et ce par quoi peut-être
pas en perdre autre site youtube tu
parlais des micro ondes les micros on a
eu comme les réseaux privés le wifi etc
la caisse est de 3 giguère tu as 30
giguère avec une longueur d'onde très
courte aussi ça marche
ah on a bien fait de se savonner un
fabio liste les longueurs d'ondés les
fréquences en fait elle nous donne une
réalité ça nous c'est notre réalité dans
une réalité ce qu'on peut entendre ce
qu'on peut voir ce qu'on peut ressentir
c'est notre réalité à nous mais c'est
pas la réalité complète et par exemple
genre t'as pas la même réalité qu'un
dieu parce qu'il n'a pas entendre les
ultras dans les petites races ont donc
ça bien sûr et puis et puis encore moins
qu'il y ait un chien ou une goutte à
chauves-souris ou tel jeu sur wii est
plein tu va maintenant je vous parlais
d'une anecdote un petit peu rigolote qui
s'est passé le 18 juillet 2010 est si
peu de bêtises je prends mon texte pour
pas dire de bêtises parce qu'on script
de ce genre de vidéos c'est clair
maîtrise pas les astronomes américains
de l'observatoire d'arecibo qui se
trouve un porto rico gravaud en capter
les ondes radio provenant de ross 128
qui est une naine rouge
j'ai cherché autour de cette naine rouge
des exoplanètes ya des petits
extraterrestres laval qui doit dresser
le fantasme et à tous les mecs sont en
train d'écouter énergie tant que ça les
écoutes guillaume pley c'est ça donc les
naines rouges évidemment à ça et mais
pas des ondes radio ils essaient en fait
d'éliminer les hypothèses les unes après
les autres pour voir quel moment donné
il tient on tombe sur un petit bonhomme
vert
on pourrait avoir une origine humaine
locales par des instruments sur terre
mais ça pourrait aussi produit par des
satellites qui communique avec la terre
pour transmettre leurs données a priori
le signal détecté ne correspond pas à ce
qu'on observe avec les satellites
habituellement les nôtres mais on peut
pas totalement l'exclure
bien vu de suspense qui se créent un
temps mais quand est ce qu'on sait en
fait l'hypothèse la plus probable c'est
que la source des ondes radio serait
plus lointaines dans l'univers et dans
le temps que cet endroit là où les ont
capturées serait une simple coïncidence
des semble venir de cette planète
inquiet par rapport à sa trajectoire
parce que c'est juste c'est pas très
loin ses envois des minières ou 130
je fais surtout et maintenant laissons
donc mais il ya une hypothèse assez
probable qu'ils pensent que ça vient de
plus loin que ça provoque et tu vois de
plus loin dans la danse et du clan li
dans l'univers alors là ouais c'est ils
ont découvert c'est au mois de juillet
pour l'instant réellement on sait pas
ils sont en train de chercher c'est le
principe des chercheurs d'ailleurs ils
sont en train de rechercher l'origine
non c'est pas et je vous informerai
rester connecté à radio fabien est donc
une ligne transition hyper logique
suite à ça un jeu propose mais qu'on
termine avec notre petite expérience
je parle un peu de des radios pirates
ah oui mais alors ça c'est toi qui va
nous en parler ouais mais en france on a
on peut pas émettre sur n'importe quel
nom de radio s'est déterminé donc c'est
légiférer way et on va dire que je n'ai
pas l'énergie par exemple
jublot 100.3 ont 35 si vous êtes un
petit malin et que vous avez un petit et
m eh ben on pour risque pas mal en
france si on émet sur une non humains
sur une fréquence n'osaient pas destiné
donc il faut faire très attention à ça
alors là ce que j'ai ici c'est un tout
petit émetteur combat on va essayer là
tout de suite et fabien c'est un petit
émetteur qui peut avoir une utilité
tout en restant dans le cadre de la loi
bien entendu je sais pas par exemple
vous êtes dans une voiture et mais vous
n'avez pas deux prises jack pour
remettre votre musique vous achetez ce
petit machin vous brancher dans votre
dans votre téléphone
et puis vous allumer la radio et la
fréquence et closer tutu mais la même
fréquence et ça l'a oublié la petite
fréquence ont choisi un truc où il ya
personne bien entendu parce que sinon
sinon bah emmerder les gens voiture à
côté ça on va donner des mauvaises idées
ce qui est très drôle c'est que denis
coderre et mais avec sa coque il arrive
avec sa jv fait voir que j'en ai bien
depuis deux fuyards incroyable fait pas
les cons mais il faut savoir que ce
qu'on appelle les radios pirates donc
les radios qui sont qui émettent sur une
fréquence où ils ont pas l'autorisation
notamment c'est quelque chose qui a
vraiment un historique et qui était
vachement développés alors un petit peu
moins maintenant mais je ne suis pas au
courant c'était vachement développé par
exemple la fin du siècle dernier
typiquement en angleterre il y avait
deux radios il y avait la bbc et la
radio d'état a enfin sauté les voilà les
trucs principaux et à l'époque les
jeunes ils voulaient écouter de la
musique du rock major c'était la pop
culture à tout ça et ils pouvaient pas
écouter ça la radio du coup bas
il y en à vide qui ont senti le filon
commandés et qu'ils ont créés ils ont
créé une radio pirate où il y en a eu
plusieurs en concurrence en fait j'étais
dans des petits bateaux jour dans la
mère dina il avait créé leurs petits pas
dissipée dans les eaux internationales
portant d'avoir serre chauffée va se
faire choper et puis il a lancé durant
toute la journée il se faisait une masse
de pognon parce que du coup ils
mettaient de pub c'est tout
je sais qu'il ya eu des films là dessus
je me souviens alors j'ai aucune
référence en tête mais je me souviens
d'avoir vu des films qui traitait un peu
de cette culture de radio pirate et
c'est avec mais qui faisaient de leur
garage qui se barre après pour faire
dans le bateau parce qu'ils avaient été
emmenés
c'est hyper intéressant qui émettent
tous une heure par mois et puis d'autres
qui se barrent vite afin qu'ils soient
sociaux p donc voilà en fait 31 ans de
sécurité n'y a pas grand chose à dire si
vous allumez votre radio et qu'il ya un
petit malin qui s'amusent à piquer le a
piqué énergie pour moi il n'en rien dire
des conneries voilà c'est pas une spin
failles de sécurité c'est juste c'est la
guerre des ondes
après il ya tellement de trucs drôles à
faire avec ça et on a tellement pas le
droit d'insulter lé faire monter un
petit peu dans ma vraie avec un truc à
très courte portée comme ça tu peux
diffusé un faux bulletin d'informations
tu vois juste à ton voisin wet wet la
mer ou à ton pote parce que je sais
qu'il est coutume à travers votre fils a
été élu le meilleur choix grève des
professeurs [ __ ] pourquoi j'avais
passé pour ce test
oui carrément alors j'ai branché la
radio alors là les amis je suis en train
de me caler sur nrj 100.3 attend mais il
est 20 heures c'est l'heure de yoplait
c'est parfait je m adresse les 20 heures
passées c'est que l'émission de
guillaume radio le monsieur guillaume
pley qui m'a imposé faire cette vidéo
on va bientôt leur tendre une fois qu'on
l'entendra je veux qu'on qui raque
énergie pour matinée de mes vidéos
dédiées pas le faire longtemps on va le
faire un peu d'argent
[Musique]
ah ouais
c'est dans micro
le team micros localise parier sur nrj
awards où on fait attention à ce qu'on
dit ça si on peut monter ce sont ces
capteurs qui existent pour faire ça avec
des chiffres jusqu'à la lie système et
vidéo entre la scène comme celle-là diaw
ses astuces guillaume sur l'énergie je
me forme à écoute pourtant on est on est
on est toujours bien sûr la radio on
espère bien cette fois vous regarde
affronter le blizzard etc et en faire
une chaîne l'année dernière qui commence
et j'en profite aussi pour vous
remercier
la dotation à voile et c'est cool m'ont
tous les soirs fois sur les moins chers
et vous pourrez choisir le placement
voilà bientôt dix ans lanouf le moment
j'écoute guillaume radio je te coupe
définitivement alors juste pour que vous
sachiez je vais vous mettre un extrait
de ce qu'a dit guillaume
quand il m'a donné cette contrainte là
et si elle dépasse un million de vues je
fais trois fois ta promo
alors oui je n'ai pas beaucoup de vidéos
qu'on fait un million de vues sur la
chaîne mais si vous voulez qu'on y fasse
à l'envers complet jeu j'en appelle à la
team mentale qu en france à elle à mes
abonnés si oui alors oui bah oui mais
bien sûr c'est sûr qu'un merci me corte
d'avoir eu cette idée en vrai c'est lui
qui a eu l'idée qu'on fasse ça avec la
radio merci beaucoup je crois que c'est
le seul moment de cette vidéo c'est
vachement drôle non pas cher c'est
excellent mais si mais c'est surtout
très interdite on met x
s'élance mais maintenant on va on va
casser ça et on va jeter lente et dans
mon cas merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à liker
surtout la partager à revenir la voir
très régulièrement aux ag de la pousser
au million et si on arrive à la pousser
au million je sais que guillaume tiendra
son engagement
je pense qu'on se fera un petit truc
directement en direct de la radio et je
lui imposerait à faire quelque chose
avec vous on réfléchira à ça on n'en est
pas là pour l'instant on est à 0 vue
puisqu'on est en train de tourner la
vidéo prenez le temps s'il vous plaît
allez découvrir la chaîne demigod c'est
aujourd'hui que tu as sorti notre vidéo
oui on a qu'une vidéo de dingue je vous
jure que c'est vrai c'est à dire que nos
tremble encore ouais on a fait ça juste
avant je pas vous spolier trop la vidéo
mais le but c'était d'essayer d'obtenir
des informations confidentielles sur
quelqu'un et c'est moi qui m'y suis
collé et on était 2 il était très drôle
envie peu je vous dis pas je vous mets
le lien de la vidéo dans la description
comme ça vous irait voir
merci beaucoup ciao ciao alors si c'est
pas encore fait tu peux aussi d'abonnés
à la chaîne simplement en cliquant sur
le petit rond que tu vois voilà juste
ici c'est ce petit rond là ça marche
depuis la tablette de téléphone c'est
extrêmement pratique il n'ya plus de
répondre attendre allez-y abonnez vous
c'est cool
[Musique]